JASON SILVA: Humanity's struggle
against death
has been our most
enduring fight.
[scream]
History has given us one weapon
in this existential battle.
We fight back with medicine.
Tens of thousands of years ago,
our ancestors scavenged
the natural world for remedies.
Imagine the incredible leaps
of faith we had to take
in an effort to ease the pain,
mend the broken,
and revive the sick.
Medicine was a dark art,
full of false starts
and false gods.
But when we struck upon
some form of relief,
it swept like wildfire
through humankind.
We built on every success
until medicine became
a form of science,
that's when we discovered
the real killers within us.
Microscopic armies hidden
within our bodies
waging war on our species
for thousands of years.
Medicine is our great weapon
to fight back
against invisible,
unthinkable death.
[screams]
From superstition to science,
medicine has become one of
humanity's most powerful tools.
And though with each
new challenge we may stumble,
we find a way to get
stronger and smarter,
to beat back fatal diseases
and extend our lifespans.
Even crack open
our genetic code.
This is the story of how
our fight against death
has determined our fate,
how it became the driving force
of our evolution.
How our tireless pursuit
of medicine has made us modern
and even made us superhuman.
This is Origins.
♪ ♪
It's the greatest
adventure story ever told,
the story of humankind and
how we created the modern world.
We're going back in time
to explore key moments,
origin moments,
that changed the course
of our shared history.
In the beginning,
survival was key,
not just from the violent threat
of instant death
posed by predators--no--
survival from
all the little things
that we take for granted today.
Infection, bacteria, disease.
Let's be honest,
anytime before the last century,
the common cold or a bug bite
could kill you.
Medicine is the name that
we gave to the magic
that allowed us to cheat death
again and again and again.
And how we learned to fight,
how we have managed to survive.
In fact, all the little miracles
that medicine brings us today,
all of it adds up to a story
about who we are as a species.
These are moments in time,
origin moments that offer
irrefutable proof,
medicine has made us modern.
And it's been a key weapon
in our fight for survival
for thousands of years.
We didn't know how old
medicine was until 1991.
Imagine, you're hiking
through the Eastern Alps
and you spot something
in the snow.
It's an ancient mummy,
the oldest and best-preserved
corpse in history.
We call him Otzi Man, and
he's more than 5,300 years old.
RAHUL JANDIAL: Otzi Man has
given us an understanding
of the origins of medicine.
When we evaluated him,
we're able to document
ancient humans' best efforts
at treating the human body.
So, Otzi Man has given us
a glimpse on how he lived,
but we also got an understanding
of how he died.
[screams]
SILVA: Otzi Man lived in a time
of brutality between humans.
Ancient tribes often
fought to the death
over life's most precious
resource, food.
[yelling]
♪ ♪
[screams]
[woman cries]
♪ ♪
[yells]
[coughing]
We know Otzi was a fighter
from the scars on his body,
but we also know that he and
his tribe were true believers
in the mysterious
healing powers of nature.
THOMAS GOETZ: Medicine was
largely a matter
of whatever was at hand.
Herbs, tree bark,
those kind of things
that may have a healing effect,
but it was really kind of
catch-as-catch-can.
JANDIAL: Today, we're inventing
medicines in the laboratory.
To do that, we needed thousands
of years of trial and error.
Plants and nature are the
foundation of modern medicine.
[thunder]
SILVA: Otzi lived in a world
of unforgiving violence,
but Otzi Man and his people
had learned
the Earth had remedies
for their pain.
Natural therapies passed down
from generation to generation,
each one improving on the last.
[shouts]
SILVA: Otzi Man put his trust,
his faith,
in the healing powers
of the Earth.
But natural medicine
could not protect him
from human brutality.
[gasps]
[yells]
[grunting]
[thud]
♪ ♪
JANDIAL: Otzi Man was
found face-down
with a flint arrowhead
in his shoulder.
We think he died of blunt force
trauma to the head.
GOETZ: Otzi Man comes from
a farming community
that was only 5,000 years
into modern man.
As a 45-year-old shepherd,
Otzi Man is a living document,
so to speak,
of the good and the bad
of those societies.
In some sense, the agricultural
economy that they were living in
was great in terms
of letting them flourish
and have stable lives
and growing families,
but then they had
to come to grips
with what are called
mismatched diseases,
such as tooth disease,
dental disease, heart disease.
All of those things that
we now think of as human life
and kind of what a lot
of people die from
is attributable to
the civilization we've created.
JANDIAL: All of a sudden,
Otzi and his people were
faced with new diseases
because of the invention
of agriculture.
They needed new remedies.
And their only resource is
the natural world around them.
Otzi Man is sort of
a champion survivalist.
It's a testament
to how well he did
that he made it into the 40s,
given how harsh the environment
must have been.
In his stomach,
there were eggs of parasites.
His toes had remnants
of frostbite.
He didn't have the medical
firepower we do now,
but he carried with him
essentially a first-aid kit.
Inside it was a mushroom,
birch polypore,
which could have been
a treatment
for his intestinal parasite.
AMANDA FOREMAN: Everyone thought
that these ancient folk remedies
from thousands of years ago
had nothing left to teach us.
But now that these synthetic
drugs have reached a plateau,
scientists are beginning
to realize
that maybe in order
to go forwards,
we need to go backwards
and discover what nature
has to offer us.
JANDIAL: Today, we're inventing
medicines in the laboratory.
But the best medicines,
the most effective medicines
were discovered from nature.
We learn from plants and nature,
and then we go to the laboratory
and try to copy them.
SILVA: Our ancestors'
surprisingly modern
and inventive medical treatments
have left scientists
scouring the Earth
and reaching back in time
for forgotten cures.
[birds squawking]
CASSANDRA QUAVE: About 80%
of the world's population
relies on plants as
a major form of medicine.
Looking around in this habitat,
you might see just
some trees and weeds,
and not really think that
there's anything special
about this area.
But what I see is different.
I see medicines.
I see cures from the past
and hopefully, for our future.
The Brazilian pepper tree berry
has a unique mechanism of action
that we've just
started to uncover.
It could be the source
of the next big medicine
in treating really nasty
infections like MRSA
in the future.
Plants make these compounds
to protect themselves.
It works not by killing the
bacteria, but by disarming it.
So, we're harnessing tools
that are already in use
to manage human infections.
We're not looking for
a needle in a haystack.
We know that people have used
these plants as medicines
for hundreds and
hundreds of years.
[camera shutter clicks]
BRIAN FAGAN:
Every traditional society
had encyclopedic knowledge
of the medicinal properties
of the plants
in their environment,
because that was the only
medicine they had.
QUAVE: During
the American Civil War,
soldiers would make teas
out of the oak bark
and use it to rinse
their wounds and infections.
Spanish moss has also
been used as a tea
to treat fever and chills.
So, all around us,
we actually are surrounded
by many interesting plants that
could serve as future medicines.
FAGAN: A lot of this
information,
which may seem bizarre
folk medicine to us,
in fact, is pharmaceutically
potentially extremely valuable.
QUAVE: I think there are many,
many more areas of medicine
that can benefit from
improving our understanding
of how these ancient remedies
actually work.
SILVA: These days, we can treat
wounds and cure diseases
that not too long ago would
have meant certain death.
But the medical skills that
made us who we are today
were built by the doctor
who got his start the hard way,
patching up gladiators in
a second century fight club.
[muffled scream]
SILVA: Humanity is cursed by the
knowledge of our own mortality.
The terrifying realization
that life is a fickle flame
that we, and all our loved ones,
are destined for the grave
drives us to find solace.
Religion told us death
is not the end.
The flesh is weak,
but the soul survives.
We could be reborn in infinite
loops of reincarnation
or live forever
in the kingdom of heaven.
To our ancestors, religion
offered more than solace.
It offered to cure
our suffering.
For thousands of years,
we invoked the supernatural
in search of remedies.
Medicine and superstition
were woven tightly together.
We turned to divination,
shamans, and white witches
to guide us to long life.
For the ancients,
no remedy was too strange.
♪ ♪
The Egyptians mixed spells
and natural cures
into magical remedies.
They pioneered bloodletting,
a cure-all around the world
for 2,000 years.
Even in our deepest desperation,
we pushed on,
slowly uncovering the truth
behind our suffering.
The pain of losing loved ones
drove us forward.
Over time, the answers began
to reveal themselves.
Superstition was giving
way to science.
♪ ♪
Medical science has come
a long way in the last century.
To our ancestors, things like
CT scans and laser surgery
might look like magic.
The medical skills that
made us who we are today
were built on a slow and steady
accumulation of knowledge
over centuries.
Medical knowledge the world over
came to a head
here in Ancient Greece.
An empire of organized learning
where the ruins of
medical treatment centers
still stand today.
FOREMAN: If you were going to be
sick in the ancient world,
I think you really wanted to be
treated by the ancient Greeks.
For one thing,
they had temples of healing.
These were called asclepeion,
which were basically the world's
first teaching hospitals.
VASSILIS LAMBRINOUDAKIS:
So, we are here
in the most famous sanatorium
of the ancient world...
FOREMAN: But not just a priest
who might say an incantation
or wave a piece of smoky feather
around you
and hope that the spirits
would leave you.
This was based on
trial and error.
Medicine was more
than just magic.
JANDIAL: Patients would visit
this ancient teaching hospital,
they would actually spend
the night and the next day,
report their dreams,
which guided the doctors to
finding the next treatment.
JANDIAL: They actually invented
and developed scalpels.
We can see evidence
of minor surgeries
when we look at the patients
that were treated
during that time.
GOETZ: Greek medicine actually
created a structure
for human disease
and human experience
that we still use today.
The Greeks created the ritual
and the process of diagnosis.
JANDIAL: Everything that
we have today
is built on the giant shoulders
of those that came before us.
Every step, every innovation,
is held on to.
That is the scientific method.
But we're continuing to build
on the legacy of thousands
and thousands of years
for the fundamental advances
for tomorrow.
SILVA: This trial and error
approach
became the scientific method,
the basis of all
modern medicine.
Observe, experiment,
formulate a hypothesis,
and then test it again and again
until it's proven false or true.
It's a method passed down to us
by the most famous graduate
of the Asklepion,
Galen of Pergamon.
Roughly 200 years after
the birth of Christ,
Galen helped lay the origins
of modern medicine.
[moaning]
GOETZ: Galen was a fight doctor
who actually managed
to write down his best practices
and writing down
what he knew to be true.
He created a corpus that
was not just useful,
but was in fact
revered for centuries.
[crowd shouting]
[growl]
♪ ♪
[grunting]
[muffled scream]
[rapid breathing]
[crowd cheering]
SILVA: With each procedure,
Galen was diving into
undiscovered territory.
Lucky for us,
he kept detailed notes
and recorded all his successes
and his failures.
[coughs]
[muffled scream]
FOREMAN: The tradition before
Galen was so bad
that you were actually
genuinely likely to die
if you went to see a doctor,
which is why Galen himself
is such an important doctor,
because he wasn't in there
simply to magic something up
and hope for the best.
He had a reason
for treating a patient,
and that patient
he expected to get better.
GOETZ: Starting with Galen,
the history of medicine
is really an effort
to see inside the human body,
to perceive what we can't see.
His discoveries and his books
were incredibly powerful,
because it allowed that
knowledge to be transferred
and disseminated to Arabia,
to Europe eventually,
and became really
the code of medicine
for the next thousand years.
Unfortunately, all of his
autopsies were done on animals,
not on humans.
BILL BRYSON:
For about a thousand years,
Galen colored modern medicine
and the treatments and
people's approaches to it,
but there was an awful lot
that was wrong,
for the principal reason that
Galen couldn't do dissections.
Religion didn't permit
people to do dissections.
Andreas Vesalius,
who was a Belgian doctor,
he came along at a time
when it became possible
to do dissections,
and to actually look
at the human body
and how it was put together.
Leonardo da Vinci, for instance,
with his anatomical drawings,
really began to create
an environment
in which medicine
and human anatomy
was looked at scientifically.
When people actually
studying with,
essentially with an open mind,
how the body works.
It's an immensely complicated
thing that we, even now,
we don't really understand
in a lot of detail.
I mean, nobody really
understands
exactly how the brain
is working, for instance.
But it was the beginning.
It was when we started
to get a handle on all this.
GOETZ: The invention
of the x-ray machine,
the invention of CT scans,
it is all a process of trying
to see what we could not see,
of trying to look
inside our bodies.
JANDIAL: Thousands of years ago,
they only looked at the surface,
and then Galen got us a little
bit deeper inside the skin,
into anatomy.
When I think about
my surgical practice now,
it wouldn't exist
if it were not for Galen.
And now with the tools we have,
we're relying on
genetics and DNA
and even atomic interactions
within our body.
So the progress
in modern medicine
is in parallel with the progress
in modern technology.
They go hand in hand.
Better tools means
a better understanding of us.
SILVA: Galen had
a seismic effect
on how your doctor treats you.
Challenging established ideas,
figuring out those missteps,
using science to
prove them wrong.
Our knowledge base is built
on thousands of years
of trial and error,
and it all adds up
to who we are now.
We have mastered
the repair of our bodies.
We can come back from what was
once deemed almost certain death
and be remade,
almost good as new.
And yet, one enemy is
always lurking, always evolving,
always surprising us with
sickness and deadly disease.
We could have been
wiped out as a species,
if not for a few origin moments
that gave us a fighting chance
against unseen,
almost undetectable killers.
SILVA: The healers of the past
fought blindly against disease
for ages.
But in the 17th century,
their hidden enemy was revealed.
Beneath the microscope,
a strange new world
came into focus.
We had our first
tantalizing glimpse
of the hidden realm inside us.
Under the lens, flesh became
a latticework of nerves,
capillaries, and blood,
each playing a unique role
in the concert of life.
Everything we thought
we knew about medicine,
about life itself
was cast into doubt.
As we plunged deeper,
we came face to face
with an alien universe
filled with miniscule creatures.
We had revealed
the realm of bacteria.
Trillions of them live and die
within every one of us.
They are central
to our survival,
yet among them are the killers
that have plagued us with
cholera, tuberculosis,
and the Black Death.
Looking deeper still,
we discovered something even
more sinister, the virus.
Secret agents in our system that
hijack the mechanics of biology.
These microbes are
our oldest enemies.
A force we have fought
for centuries.
Over the ages, these tiny armies
have killed billions.
With medicine,
we bring the fight to them.
We live in the Information Age.
An epoch where information can
spread to billions of people
around the globe
instantaneously.
Information that can illuminate,
entertain, and save lives.
In the recent outbreaks of SARS,
measles, and Ebola,
transmission of information
was crucial
to stop disease in its tracks.
But imagine finding yourself
stripped of all access
to information
and in the midst
of one of the deadliest plagues
known to humankind
where over the course
of a few centuries,
half of the entire population
of Europe was lost.
This was Europe
in the 16th century.
Black Death stole
up to 200 million lives.
It was an invisible,
relentless tidal wave
washing over the world
for hundreds of years.
[cough]
DIANA PRESTON: Medicine in
the early Middle Ages in Europe
was pretty rudimentary.
A lot of it was to do
with superstition
rather than any sort
of rational treatments.
You might as well have expected
if you had a bad wound
to have someone press
a dead rat to it
in the hopes that
that would cure it.
SILVA: In 1528, one young doctor
was determined
to fight the plague
with science.
His name was
Michel de Nostredame,
better known as Nostradamus.
JANDIAL: When we think
of Nostradamus,
we think about
all his prophecies,
but actually he was a plague
doctor taking care of the sick,
as a young clinician.
[coughing]
We know now the Black Death
is an infection,
but back then they didn't know,
so they blamed everything
from God to foreigners
and even earthquakes.
[bell tolling]
[coughing]
[loud bang]
[footsteps]
[knock on door, woman screams]
♪ ♪
[screams]
[door slams]
♪ ♪
[crying]
[horse whinnies]
♪ ♪
JANDIAL: Nostradamus'
contribution to the Black Death
was getting people
to boil water,
was getting people to bury
their dead.
This led to a whole new
awareness for sanitation
and its link with health.
GOETZ: The invention
of sanitation,
the recognition that
we needed to have sewers,
that we needed
to take human waste
and move it as far as possible
from human settlements.
That was in many ways
the greatest invention
one would say of medicine.
FOREMAN: What separates
town dwellers from nomads,
people who live
in nomadic societies
can just get up and walk away.
Town dwellers can't.
And why this is important
is because town dwellers
have to deal with
their own refuse.
That required organization.
It required politics.
It required a system
of sanitation.
You're seeing the beginnings of
what we now call civic society.
GOETZ: If you want to just count
the number of lives saved,
sanitation is perhaps
one of the greatest discoveries
we've ever made.
SILVA: The plague pandemics
are a prime example
of how lack of knowledge
and the inability to spread
accurate information
can lead to false assumptions.
At every turn in our existence,
the quest for truth
by examination
has provided the key
to our survival
in the face of disaster.
When we started to get
a clearer picture of our body
and how our system works,
we discovered we are not alone.
We now know we carry
life-forms within us,
trillions upon trillions, many
of them good, some of them bad.
The first discovery
of these microbes
opened a whole new battlefront
in the war against disease.
It's a fight that
continues today,
attacking the origins
of illness itself,
beating back
the specter of death!
SILVA: We know today that our
macroscopic world is controlled
by microscopic beings.
Most of them help us,
but some microbes are killers.
Medical technology
is now so powerful
we can see them in fine detail.
But in the 19th century,
doctors had no idea
what caused epidemics
of cholera, yellow fever,
influenza, measles,
diseases that ravaged
the most sophisticated
modern societies on Earth.
BRYSON: A lot of
the very finest minds
put themselves to the challenge
of understanding the human body
and illness and how they work.
But the problem is
that the human body
is a very complex thing,
and they didn't understand
one of the basic mechanisms,
which is that a lot
of what determines
how healthy we are or not
is invisible, it's microbial.
SILVA: Imagine what
it must have been like
to look into a microscope
and see for the first time
organisms invisible to the eye,
operating in our blood,
within our bodies.
But how would you know
if you were looking at
the product of a disease
or its cause?
This was the central question
facing a young doctor
working in the outskirts
of the German empire in 1875.
His name was Robert Koch.
♪ ♪
GOETZ: Robert Koch was a country
doctor in a small town
that was filled
with sheep farmers
and had an outbreak of anthrax.
They asked him to find out what
was killing the local sheep.
So Koch started
a series of experiments.
Robert Koch believed
the germ theory of disease,
that disease could spread
by means of microbes,
these things we observed
under microscopes.
People had observed bacteria
for many hundreds of years.
There was no way to prove
that that had anything to do
with causing the disease.
In fact, it was thought
that they resulted
as a consequence of the disease.
[gasps]
GOETZ: So Koch took the blood
of the local sheep,
and he moved it
to another animal.
And that animal died.
♪ ♪
[ticking]
He saw bacteria in the blood
that had an outbreak of anthrax.
GOETZ: After he had reproduced
the disease in 20 or 30 animals,
and in each case seen the blood
go from pure and clean
to infested
with these pathogens,
Koch had actually created
a chain of evidence
that had identified that
there was in fact one bacteria,
one pathogen that
caused this disease.
The germ theory of disease
became a true breakthrough
of medicine.
BRYSON: Right up until
the time of Koch,
a common notion was that
maladies were caused by bad air.
Miasmas, as they were known.
I mean, malaria means 'bad air.'
It just seems
so counterintuitive,
the idea that something
small and invisible
could make you ill
and even kill you.
GOETZ: Eventually,
Robert Koch started to make
this amazing pattern
of discoveries.
Typhus, anthrax, tuberculosis.
All these diseases that caused
millions of deaths a year
were suddenly catalogued
and identified
as being caused by bacteria.
And so Robert Koch signs up
to give a lecture
in a library in Berlin.
The doctors in the room
were there to challenge Koch.
They had staked their careers
on arguing against germs.
And he finished his lecture, and
the room was completely silent.
Paul Ehrlich, another famous
scientist who was in the room,
said he knew that he had
witnessed a pivotal moment
in medical history.
And the world had
suddenly changed.
FOREMAN: The ability to identify
and prevent infectious diseases
is the key to almost all
of modern medical science.
Without it, humanity can die
in a matter of months.
GOETZ: The germ theory
of disease
led us to the creation
of vaccines,
and that was a pivotal moment.
FOREMAN: We haven't yet
conquered death, obviously,
but one of the things
that we have conquered
thanks to vaccinations
is the insane infant mortality
rate that used to exist.
A hundred years ago, families
had to be of, you know,
three, four, five,
seven children,
because at least half of them
weren't going to make it
to adulthood.
And of course it prevented women
from having careers,
having lives outside
of the family.
But thanks to vaccinations,
we can be pretty sure that
the children we give birth to
are going to make it.
Suddenly, you now only need
to have one or two children.
Women are no longer just baby
machines, they are human beings.
And so you have
the rise of feminism.
You get the rise
of the middle classes.
So in fact, there's this huge
social revolution
that comes out of this
medical revolution.
SILVA: The collective wisdom
of all of humankind
led to the medical advancements
that made us modern.
We're attacking the things that
harm us on a microscopic level.
We're finding new ways
of preventing disease every day.
The question is,
how far can we go?
JANDIAL: What seems to be
fantasy and sci-fi
in the world of health
and the human body
is actually just right
around the corner.
Imagine having your own personal
catalog of replacement tissue
sitting on a shelf.
We can tweak a skin cell
and turn it into a brain cell
and rebuild your body parts.
That's the horizon,
and it's not far away.
It's not 50 years away.
It's going on right now.
DEVIN LEAKE:
This lab is to genetics
what the printing press
was to written word.
ELIZABETH NICKERSON: Here in
this lab, we synthesize DNA,
so a lot of people have heard
about the Human Genome Project
where DNA was decoded,
but here what we're doing is
actually building pieces of DNA.
The DNA code in every cell
is not only a source
of information,
for example, your eye color,
your hair color, your height,
but it's also
a source of control
of different processes
in your body,
things like regenerating cells
at different speeds
in different parts of your body.
LEAKE: It's an incredible,
incredible technology.
Our overarching goal is
making DNA ubiquitous,
to make it available
to everyone.
KEVIN MUNNELLY: The things that
we're working on right now
we know can be game changing,
better, more specific drugs,
personalized drugs.
NICKERSON: We're enabling a lot
of different types of projects.
But I always like to think
about the people
that are studying cancer.
There's been a lot of cancer
in my family.
Cancer is a very
dynamic disease.
But if you can
accelerate research,
then you can actually create
a designer therapy
for a specific tumor.
And the faster you can do that,
the earlier you can intervene,
and that's everything in cancer.
MUNNELLY: In the world
of synthetic biology,
it's either going to be
the thing that saves humanity
or the thing that
kills humanity.
So we're part of an organization
that self-polices
in the industry.
We have different protocols
to ensure that none of us
will design and build something
harmful to humanity.
LEAKE: I think as we think
about medicine,
this is the next revolution
in medicine.
This is the ability to really
create personalized medicine.
It's an opportunity
to help humankind.
SILVA: With the discovery of DNA
and the mechanisms of genetics,
we have discovered
the language of life.
We have realized that we are
linguistic all the way down.
DNA is code,
and we are diving deeper
into what makes us
uniquely human.
We are repairing flaws
that have built up
over millennia of evolution,
so we can chase off death
and thrive in this modern world
today and beyond tomorrow.
As Alan Harrington once wrote,
'Any philosophy
that accepts death
must itself be considered dead,
its questions meaningless,
its consolations worn out.'
Across time,
the advancement of medicine
has done more than save lives.
It has given us
a new understanding
of ourselves and our world.
We have grasped
the inner workings
of our bodies and our minds.
We have gazed upon the very
building blocks of life,
the clockwork of biology
that makes us tick.
We have even discovered
an entirely new way of thinking.
Through medicine, powerful ideas
about logic and reason
have taken root and
blossomed into science.
Even when the unknown
outweighed the known,
even as we fought
an invisible enemy,
we refused to accept
the inevitable.
With medicine,
we have seized our own fate.
We owe it all to the visionaries
of medicine,
the healers and thinkers
who paved the way.
We have come far.
Our species is on the verge
of medical revolutions
that will change what
it means to be human.
As we turn to face the future,
we fight death with more power
than ever before,
standing on the shoulders
of giants.
We are ready to face
the unknown.
♪ ♪
We will fight until we see
the end of disease...
...and just maybe,
the end of death.
♪ ♪
[bell tolling]